quisiera empezar preguntándole que le
llevó a escribir su libro
pues fueron diez años de investigación
en los cuales me di cuenta que hay una
relación una conversación y una conexión
entre las diferentes formas de conectar
la cultura y las visiones culturales
entre tanto colombia como mexico y me di
cuenta que era necesario tener esa
conversación
la literatura no se basa sólo en la
visión de cómo desarrollamos la vida
sino también de cómo generamos esta
conversación cómo construimos la charla
y cómo llegamos a ella y precisamente
antes de emprender estos diez años que
nos cuentan de investigaciones partía de
alguna concepción que le haya cambiado
durante este proceso aprendió algo que
no esperaba no muchísima gente fueron
diez años
en revisiones tanto en
periódicos en revistas
y libros guardados
incluso en colecciones de diferentes
tipos que me llevaron a mostrar a mi
tanto públicas como privadas de
encontrar mucha información distinta que
pudimos ver en nuestro libro la idea es
que al final todas las opciones de medio
en colombia siempre ha sido una
conversación siempre ha existe una
relación nuestros vasos comunicantes que
siempre están desarrollándose y que
siempre se están hablando entre uno y el
otro lado digamos hay algo de lo que me
gusta decir es que el libro más
importante uno de los libros más
importantes de colombia que es 100 años
de soledad fue escrito en mexico como se
construyó ese pasado como se construyó
ese link o como generamos esa relación
es uno de los puntos que quiero tener
dentro de ésta
dentro de esta conversación y
precisamente como usted lo mencionaba es
conocida la relación entre el autor
colombiano garcía márquez con mexico a
quien otros autores y artistas podríamos
hacer referencia
claro creo que la relación de méxico
colombia no es solo literaria y de
pintura como rómulo rosso que tuvo una
relación muy grande digamos con los
pintores de muralismo como rivera
siqueiros y demás pero hay un gran
fotógrafo maravilloso como leo matiz
colombiano que tuvo una relación muy
grande con méxico y desde porfirio barba
jacob siguiendo con que es un gran
fotógrafo también podemos hablar de
neumática es un gran fotógrafo pero
también podemos hablar de porfirio barba
jacob que es un gran poeta y después
álvaro mutis que es muy conocido y
seguir con garcía márquez y terminar con
fernando vallejo siempre desarrollos en
una existido siempre hay una
conversación constante en esta visión y
lo maravilloso de todo esto es eso es
darnos cuenta que hay países
latinoamericanos que siempre quieren
conversar siempre están
desarrollándose apoyándose y además no
sólo es una competencia así también sino
también un apoyo para mirar más allá y
precisamente que se puede decir de esta
conversación a día de hoy entre méxico y
colombia de esta conversación a cultural
social
pues imagínate yo creo que viene antes
de que los países sean reconocidos como
países siempre hemos visto que se ha
transformado que se ha desarrollado esta
relación entre colombia y siempre se va
manejando manejando manejando
transformando y ahora es algo distinto
pero esa transformación sigue siendo muy
importante
las relaciones entre miguel colombia
culturalmente antes eran eran poéticas
luego fueron culturales en temas de
manejo de nuestra visión pero ahora son
otras formas de contar nuestras
historias y siempre va a existir siempre
nos vamos a ver y siempre vamos a
entendernos a partir de lo que es una
conversación una
forma de texto de conectarnos como dos
países